well let's turn our attention back to
the race for number 10 now the former
chancellor rishi sunak is promising more
handouts to help people get through the
cost of living crisis if he wins the
tory leadership contest he says he'll
offer support to everyone with
particular focus on pensioners and the
most vulnerable well let's find out a
little bit more now shall we i'm joined
by the conservative mp and supporter of
rishi sunak dr liam foxx uh very good
morning to you good to see you and so
richie sunaka's written in the times
about this hasn't he today setting out
his latest plans to tackle these costs
of living pressures let me just read out
one extract of that to you he says
if it requires some limited and
temporary one-off borrowing as a last
resort to get us through this winter i'm
prepared to do that uh he's opening the
door to borrowing isn't he i mean isn't
that a u-turn after all he's said about
this trust's plans well you have to have
read the paragraphs before that not just
that one which says that this is an
absolute last resort not a first resort
the key thing is that global energy
prices are remaining very high
and that's a result of the fact that
global production has not caught up with
global demand because people who did the
maintenance and the production they
suffered from covert too the people
transporting the oil by sea they had
covered two so there's an ongoing
disruption in the global economy the
question is is are we going to protect
the most vulnerable during that period
this is not a shift in policy uh towards
borrowing in the way that i think liz
truss's policy which was to borrow to
cut taxes is a long-term shift this is a
response to a specific problem and i
think it shows that he fully understands
what the most vulnerable in our society
will be facing and yet he has spent
weeks trashing liz truss's borrowing
plans hasn't he saying that it's immoral
to pass the burden on to the next
generation so he's undermining his own
argument not at all i've just explained
why because what she's saying is let's
borrow money to cut taxes in the hope
that it will stimulate demand further
well the problem at the moment is demand
is already outstripping supply which is
why we've got inflation what he's saying
is that let's try uh first of all we've
got the windfall uh tax on the energy
companies then let's look at public
spending projects to see if we can save
that money so that we can ensure that
the help is available to the vulnerable
only in a very last resort and for a
one-off reason would we want to see
further boring so there's quite a big
difference okay and so let's look at
what he is preparing to offer he's
talking about 10 billion pounds worth of
hell but 5 billion of that is that the
vat plan that he's already announced on
energy bill so are we talking about five
billion of new money and if so is that
enough well it's 10 billion of new help
um what he said is that that's already
been the summit's been announced but
it's not been spent and it's not uh the
money's not yet available in that sense
so
what it says is that yes we understand
rishi understands that there is a need
to help people further as long as this
energy price emergency continues
eventually of course prices are likely
to fall as global supply comes back up
to the levels that we had before but
there's going to be a period where help
will be required and it's responsible
socially responsible to ensure that that
help is available and how far will that
five billion of newly announced money
how far will that go the consumer
consumer champion martin lewis has
talked about the need to double the
amount of support that's available i
mean the last lot of new support was
worth about 15 billion so this this
isn't going to go far enough well that
supports some of that support of course
is is still coming through the pipeline
uh another 10 billion would be a huge
help on that but as rishi said we have
to wait to see what the cap looks like
before we can calculate exact costs but
it's right to say in principle that
those who need help those who are
watching your program who are afraid
that they won't be able to heat their
homes through the winter have the
reassurance that a government led by
rishi sunet would be on this side and
how soon will that help come and who
will get it well it will depend again on
the size of what the cap is and it will
be targeted largely at those who are
most in need pensioners for example was
on fixed incomes those for whom are cut
in tax wouldn't actually help them at
all um it's it's going to have to be
targeted at those most in need because
those
these are the people who may simply not
heat their homes
may be unable to meet some of their
bills they're the ones who are going to
require the biggest help they're the
ones who can't raise their income well
yes and
targeted help
for the vulnerable they will say that's
what we need and others will say why go
for it for a rebate for all like is
currently was in his plans as chancellor
the 400 pounds was that the wrong
approach well it's targeted isn't it
there's a there's a
rebate for everybody and then there's
extra help so that ranges from 400
pounds per household to 1200 pounds if
you're in the most vulnerable groups i
think that's the right way to do it and
i think that the tax on the energy
companies which is uh as you can imagine
there's a free market here i wouldn't
normally support but i think that
windfall taxes should only be on
windfall profits and if the companies
are making unusually large profits
because of the very high global prices
as a result of the pandemic it's fair
that the government cushions that blow
to consumers
and what about for
anyone on benefits for pensioners
watching for those on lower incomes can
rishi sunac guarantee that they will not
fall short when the october price cap is
announced well the aim will be to
protect those people
can they think well no i don't need to
find them
i can't tell you that because i don't
know what the cap is going to be this
morning but the aim is very clear
the aim from rishi sunak is to say we
understand that we can't simply say
we'll cut taxes because that would help
those who are actually at the bottom end
who are not paying taxes on fixed
incomes they're the ones who have got to
get the the biggest amount of help as
you correctly say at the moment we're
giving help to all households but extra
help to those in most need that seems to
me both economically and morally the
best way forward is it problematic for
rishi sunak that he's been chancellor
until a few weeks ago and today we get
figures
showing that our growth is contracting
in this country does that reflect on him
and his management of the economy no no
more than it does the fact the american
economy is contracted for two quarters
in a row this is a global problem
pandemics don't just stop in their
effects when the health position gets
better there are long-term economic
ripples that come out from pandemic
which is why we're seeing that around
the world
and i think that what it does show is
that we need to have a very clear grasp
of the problems we face number one being
inflation that we must get control of
and the second is that we must
gear our economy up by investment to
grow in the future that's a responsible
plan we know that that the rise in
prices isn't just an economic problem it
is actually a social and a moral problem
too which is why it's got to be the
number one priority for the next prime
minister i'm going to let you go in just
a moment a very quick question last
night richie sunak said that uh boris
johnson wasn't returning his text
messages or calls does that bother him
i wouldn't know whether that bothers him
i don't think it's all that surprising
is it to most of us i imagine that boris
johnson is uh planning other things and
may have less time for uh the immediate
politics around the leadership election
so uh no surprise not really okay liam
fox thanks very much indeed for coming
in